hey Greg knuckles here with string
theory calm and today we're talking
about the bench press
specifically strength out of the bottom
portion of the bench press and options
to give you a longer range of motion
specifically the question I was asked
was about flat-backed bench a lot of
geared ventures tend to bench for all
more often in the offseason to
strengthen their bench off the chest
because that's something that is
neglected and geared work so the
question was would benching with a flat
back as opposed to an arch do the same
thing for a role venture and potentially
it would but I still wouldn't recommend
it simply because there are better
options it basically comes down to a
risk to reward calculus and it's not
that benching with a flat back is
inherently risky it might be more so for
some people than others
but there are clearly a lot of people
who have benched with a flat back their
entire lives and never got shoulder
problems Jennifer Thompson is a good
example she has a relatively flat back
to pinch and is absurdly strong
I think she's benched 308 at 132 and has
never had any shoulder problems that I'm
aware of Mike McDonald who is a great
venture of yesteryear he he benched I
think 606 at 242 and 582 at 220 he was
also a relatively flat back bencher
never had any shoulder problems that I'm
aware of
so yeah you can definitely bench some
people can definitely bench with a flat
back and never have shoulder issues but
some people will so I wouldn't recommend
flat back benches just as a general
recommendation simply because for some
people they do carry risks and there are
other options that can help you
accomplish the same thing that flat back
benches would that don't carry the same
risks so that's what I'll be talking
about in this video so number one is the
close grip bench
a lot of people think of the Close Grip
primarily as a triceps exercise but when
you actually think about it when your
grip moves them a little closer
your elbow ends up being a bit lower
than the bars on your chest versus if
your grip is wider so close grip bench
een actually helps you work through that
longer range of motion as well the next
thing would be floor press that doesn't
necessarily give you a longer range of
motion but it forces you to start the
press from a dead stop without any
assistance from your legs and most
people are actually a little bit weaker
a couple inches off the chest then right
on the chest so that weakness out of the
bottom of a bench floor press can help a
lot of people with that the next one is
Paul's benching if you're not already
doing pause benches and you're a power
lifter then you probably should because
you need to do them for competition if
you're not looking to compete and you're
used to just benching touch-and-go then
pitching with the short pause can help
you develop some of that strength out of
the bottom if you're used to benching
with the pause than benching with a
slightly longer one can serve the same
purpose the next one is what's been
called lately this photo press after
Eric's photo who has the all-time world
record benchpress at super heavy weight
but people have been doing this exercise
forever basically it's a polished bench
press but instead of pausing with the
bar on your chest you let it hover about
half an inch off of your chest so you
actually have to continue controlling
the weight and you can't actually let it
rest on your chest and let your body
support the weight the next one is
benching with your feet up again you can
still do this with an arch it can be the
exact same bench stroke except you have
to actually use your pecs triceps
shoulders to produce more of the force
to lift the bar off of your chest since
you don't have the assistance of leg
drugs and the next one is pin press with
the bar starting right around your chest
either barely touching your chest or
barely hovering off of it you can still
use leg drive with this but what it does
is since you're not lowering the weight
beforehand you don't have that
Rett reflux and the elastic energy from
the eccentric part of the muscle to help
you reverse the weight so it also helps
build strength out of the hole there are
two final options that aren't actually
benchpress variations that serve this
purpose very well also the first is
dumbbell press because with a dumbbell
you don't have to worry about the bar
stopping you right here you can keep
going a little bit lower and unlike flat
back bench you're not locked into a
pronated hand position you can do them
with a neutral grip so if it does start
causing shoulder discomfort you can
instead of dumbbell benching here as you
lower it you can do a neutral grip to
take some of that stress off of your
shoulders and another one for similar
reasons would be dips again because you
can do them with a neutral grip a more
shoulder friendly option that still
allows for a longer range of motion
obviously don't take any of this as
physical therapy or rehab advice or
anything like that I'm just a dude who
lifts heavy weights giving you advice
about lifting heavy weights so all of
these options I just went through today
I see them as things with the same
potential upside as flat back bench that
carry fewer risks but obviously none of
them are completely risk-free as making
up heavy things is not completely
risk-free and some of them may cause you
more discomfort than others so I give
you a pretty long list of options so
just go with the ones that are more
comfortable for you because they all
accomplish basically the same purpose so
if one of them is more comfortable in
one of them hurts obviously go with the
one that's more comfortable alright guys
so this was a Q&A video I'm going to
start doing these more often so if you
have questions ask them in the comments
below if I like them then I'll respond
to them if I don't then I probably won't
respond to them but I will appreciate
that you asked so that's it guys please
like and subscribe thanks for watching